hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker
now we're still in the Mario challenge
and we're still on normal after I
finished a normal one I'm gonna start up
the expert one and see what kind of hell
it throws at me I'm pretty sure I can
just run from this
run run Forrest okay that was the exact
answer that I needed hey hey oh [ __ ] I
need to throw it I forgot bang oh [ __ ]
that hardly did anything that I needed
it to do oh god this is exact opposite
of the good yeah okay oh [ __ ] you come
on you bastard you stole my ride what is
this grand theft Mario screw here we go
okay now that we got that some of them
are dead now ah I'm dead too I was one
of the some come on come on come on I
can do this I can do this once I just
learned the trick I'll be able to do it
fast and efficiently boink and gothe
right through into here we go we got it
we got tongue and fire action going on
oh I love the little angry face on them
it's so adorable oh so cool I'll just
eat some of that thank you for it what
do you think I'm honorable I'm gonna
fight a fair fight now I'm gonna skip
straight to the end if I can and then
run away as fast as I am a human capable
of doing so alright get ready get ready
for the pain get ready for the Thunder
oh come on come on you see what is in
your mouth
okay thank you for catching me I'm glad
you were here for me in the end when I
need to do the most let's just squat
down here you keep holding your breath
little buddy till you eventually turn
for Lulu
I was like the blue Yoshi better anyway
so I'm glad you're appreciating my needs
of it oh I got a new world record cool
no one was nuts mmm delicious water very
professional would be drinking it while
I record but it's okay you guys
understand okay now these two and then
I'm going to start the expert ones and
see where that one takes me because it's
going to be nuts let's go down oh god
this is moving really fast Lee oh God
I guess I could have gone above them
that probably would have been very
advantageous for me maybe I can't go
above them for too long I'm a
happy-go-lucky little propeller dude I
don't know if this supposed to be going
there's a little drug up there by some
forms they all seem so peaceful in
sleeping I never did understand how
whomps were able to just hover in midair
and if anything why were they only able
to go up or go down smash why can't they
do an up smash I guess that's the advent
of the giant pillars of dildo coming at
you from out of the walls but at the
same time I guess whenever they go back
up they go back up real lethargic like
it's a mystery of Mario who knows these
things I certainly do not okay
flaunt Falls good name all right there's
the last one in the normal and then
we're gonna roll right on to the experts
I don't know how I'm gonna do with that
one the answer is probably not very good
but I'm gonna try my bit what is this
sir I'm no fool
I'm no fool here but it let's see okay
here we go what what am I supposed oh oh
okay oh oh oh not yet okay we made it
something I don't know how we did that
oh god this was a mistake mistake
mistakes
Oh mistakes were made mistakes were made
mistakes were made
alright try that again I think what was
this love of them super super easy okay
I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure
whoops didn't mean to do that drop down
there we go see what happens see where
we're going with this one
Oh God missing it missing it missing it
wolf okay I'm just a poor little baboo
don't mind me here we go okay oh no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
raining hammers oh god oh god mistakes
were made where are they supposed to go
with that one I guess I was supposed to
still have the propeller beanie but I I
lost it
so if I lose it that I'm not I'm just
screwed it seems a little it seems a
little unforgiving to be honest I think
they threw in one expert level towards
the end er just a mess with people okay
Oh God
foolish foolish loggers Oh Gilly years
Oh Oh go down okay
now this one is gonna go a lot easier
because I am going to wait till the very
end to do this and then blue go down and
go down
no don't lose oh come on why that one
guy throw that way one guy throw the
other way when everyone else why did he
have to go against the grain
doesn't everyone own it you're not
supposed to be original an individual
this [ __ ]
just [ __ ] guys again it's time with
a little less suck I mean I I normally
add gratuitous amounts of suck to every
game that I play but this time I'm gonna
try to mix it up just put some big take
for [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] balls and fudge
bags here try going this one he's gonna
work out he worked out
Oh whose whose fault before I was ready
to for it to fall okay so if I go a
little bit early
then I'd actually fall generally I
screwed myself over I screwed myself
over I screwed myself over Oh God
run run Oh run faster oh where am I
going now please tell me that's the last
hurdle than I needed to cry oh god oh
god what is this can I please go down
here thank you
I don't know where here leads to but I
hope it's any better than where I was
okay that's why I don't oh god oh god no
no no you didn't tell me didn't tell me
it was like that okay we go here we go
run for it run for it run Forrest run
run okay so
all right so that's that's just that's a
whole lot of death right there wow
that's that's how a bunch are death but
I gotta imagine that around here just
yeah alright oh god yes [ __ ] burn you
bastards so I don't know what how I went
where did I go that I was off in
swampland thought I wasn't supposed to
be there cuz obviously I wasn't supposed
to be there I have a feeling that you
could have like spin jumped on all those
swamp full moms I'm getting all four for
record here oh no don't tell me my
princess is in another castle
oh hi princess
I'm your hero do I get cake and a kiss
each other
oh it's progressively better rewards the
harder difficulty than you go through Oh
here's everyone that made those levels
Thank You Isabelle Liam at Beast hashtag
beast service Ava or pound sign
ninjas calm Ava fluid Jin Fulbright a
sure dad thanks dad Joey
Kyla Marcel the cubed that Japanese name
rawr and jimster okay
so there we go whoa that was an
adventure but now we're gonna get a
taste of what expert um the woolly world
nice anyway we're gonna get a taste of
what expert has to offer us in it I have
a funny feeling it ain't gonna be too
easy it's still 16 levels though
apparently wolf things get dark and
dreary alright let's go for it let's see
what happens I imagine this is gonna be
very difficult for me but I'm gonna try
to get through the first one and if I
can get through the first one in less
than a few lives everything's gonna work
out
not probably not probably death awaits
me okay ah why who's son of a [ __ ] why
would you do that
you can't just surprise me right off the
bat with that okay thank you
how am I supposed to be able to get in
there how am I supposed to be able to
survive any of this you do whoa what the
[ __ ] I what was that did he
intentionally put that there so it bug
it out probably what the hell well it's
so weird okay can I get in here yeah I
can okay
but this doesn't help me much at all but
I could get in technically right here
okay damn it okay there we go god okay
so now that I'm in here what do I get
what do I get what do I get oh boy
that doesn't really help me much oh no
this is not fairs it's not off to a good
start these expert levels are going to
be habeas I don't know how anyone would
be able to finish the like super expert
level shut up it's not too difficult I
got this I got it what you talking about
I got it okay so don't go there that bad
oh [ __ ] you troll troll damn it okay now
we need to get serious we need to learn
that there's tricks at every us
okay at the end of it it's at the end of
it it's at the end of it all right okay
so we got that why would you do that
what else am I supposed to do maybe
maybe you're supposed to go up here ah
this looks like a thing unless it's deaf
it could be dance it could very well be
deaf but this is a thing at least Oh God
Oh No got it got it got it got it got it
got it got it got it I got it I got this
I got this I got this so what am I
supposed to do here okay okay what does
this mean I just stuck here for all
eternity now I I don't know I don't know
I don't know guys I don't know I don't
know I don't know oh damn oh shoot 13
lives on this level alone not a good
sign there we go now what happens if I
just wait here for something to come
along here because this looks like a
track I'm just gonna end up waiting
forever that's just gonna repel me I'm
not even gonna be able to get in there
what is that what a load a porpoise hork
alright screw this I can't do it I can't
do it I can't do this God the first
level on expert I can't do this is bull
there's got to be like a special way to
do this but not enough people have
played it that there's any clues there's
no clues no one's commented anything on
this okay so that is all the time I got
for Super Mario maker here I will try
the expert 100 Mario challenge soon I'm
just gonna need to think about this
don't look at me like that Mario you
turn your gaze somewhere else please put
your head under your hat so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what I should do in the next video
besides the super early
for Jones but that's probably next on my
list so thanks again everybody and as
always I will see you in the next video